Các quan trích cấp cao trong chính quyền tổng thống Mỹ đồ năng tròa, đã tổ chức mặt của họ tạng nhà trong tổng thần
vừa qua, để thảo lượng gắng lửa trọn căn thêm 14 vào phía này dây la, các cuộc họp gió hội đồng
aning nổi đi ở phục trách, vừa một các quan trích trủ chốt, như phó tổng thống GDVNC,
COVID-19 mới lờ một trường trên trang mới đi phát hành hành sĩ và trụ tịch khói đồng thống như trưởng Dan King,
tổng thống trong trường tiếp dự 1 trong có cuộc họp tải phòng tình guống và được chính bài nhiều con an, trong đó có khả năng
tổng thống công trên bộ, các cuộc họp giận ra trong buổi cảnh Washington đang tăng cường hình diện của sử tại buồn k bê sau hài tháng thiệt hành cá cũng tận công gây chép người,
nhằm vào tổ thuyền đi vui mà tì h影 hại khơi về này dây la, một tổ xanh bài nhiều tình biết em à mấy lâm, tổ chuyến và một tổ nằm hạt nhân,
đã được nhà trắng điều đó, có khu vực cùng năng đi bình sĩ, cho lệ báo chi ông Trump mọi gần như đã có quy định về khả năng hành động của sử,
có nhiều thêm chí tiet, về biê bên này dưới la, các roc cá sạo buộc Washington đang tìm cách lập lộ,
trong thống đi của la, sma đồ người mà Mỹ cũng đang chào thưởng nằm miệnh chế lâu, bơi cáu buộc dính liệu tế hả năng bộ bản mặt ý,
bên này dưới la được cho là cũng đã chình thái bu khí và chuẩn bị chình lơ khán cơ trong trường hợp bị mi tàn cộng.